so kevin you're smart guy what are your
thoughts on censorship and as a youtuber
there's plenty other youtubers out there
how do you address that
oh yeah i mean there's there's obviously
always a balance to everything but
i think sometimes uh or or the needle
right now is too
far uh to the extreme do you think
there's a balance on censorship
well i mean look there are some things
like if somebody's
uh live streaming a mass shooting yeah
that should be censored right that that
should not be live
but that doesn't happen i mean yeah it
actually it has happened but but okay
why well what do you mean why whoa okay
we want to get into the fundamentals
yeah so i mean look
that's that's a simple one if if
somebody can livestream a mass
shooting and and become internet famous
uh for a few hours
create internet celebrity and then die
and kill themselves or whatever
what does that do that motivates others
to be martyrs and do the same thing
with that society has to censor that so
there is
as with everything there's a spectrum
there's there's the middle
there's one extreme and there's the
other right now i think we're a little
bit too far to one extreme but we can't
be
zero either okay well it's i mean it's
interesting right because
you you talk about what is i guess to
your point all right it's a good point
he's got shot glasses we have a party
next
it's a good point that you made you
drink tequila let's go what you're
talking about
yeah you're talking about maybe we'll
have some tequila in a minute yeah so so
it's a good point that you make but
you're talking about
um incentivizing behavior and
de-incentivizing behavior
disincentivizing yeah right yeah
and specific to this to your point okay
and it's a
it's a good point well made they're
literally disincentivizing
telling the truth well yeah so it's it's
they're using the excuse of you can't
cover a mass murder because it would
incentivize
mass murder and that's fine okay fair
now it's it this the pendulum is
currently
they're literally disincentivizing
truth-telling
you literally have to just regurgitate
our lines say the party line
or have your entire business shut down
where where are you seeing this or
uh in journalism or on youtube or
everything
this is not something that that i'm
making up this is something bill maher
has covered extensively this is
something that
that even pete jon stewart this is
people that are on the quote unquote
left
are actually finally starting to catch
up russell brand talks about this all
the time and this is a situation
specific to us
where patrick is literally we we had a
meeting two days ago where people
in a project a very very expensive
project are begging him
not to go forward with this information
which has since been cooperated
after they've already talked about it
after it's already been done we've not
released it 20
yeah so again so i understand the point
so the if the if the point of not
showing something is to
disincentivize it are they not showing
specifically and i have to be honest
with you
the tech companies in california who who
tend to be
democrat and liberal are they
intentionally
to use your word disincentivizing the
truth
i don't know if it's intentional i think
there
is um you know i don't know i don't know
i think it deserves more looking into i
mean i think that's one of the things
the beautiful things about if you get in
to a position of power you become
governor
you see much more and you could take the
same reason that we use on my youtube
channel or in this discussion
and you can apply it with the actual
information that we have because
look we don't have all the information
like you said yourself we don't have all
the information as outsiders
i'd love to know more when you have that
information let's say you get in as
governor okay and you have a a a big
lion backing you that maybe you can
go toe-to-toe with some of these tech
companies yeah what would you do let's
just say you have some information
you come from youtube you come from the
tech world you're sitting there and it's
zuckerberg it's dorsey
it's whoever runs uh the google
conglomerate right now you're in
you're at the room with them and you say
all right the censorship thing what are
we going to do about it and your
solution is
well it's all it look it all comes down
to nuance that's it's the same thing
when folks want to know how do i invest
in real estate there's no one answer
i've got to know the details can i can i
push back a little bit so
let me tell you what the audience is
saying yes here the audience is saying
kevin why are you being a politician
that's what they are but
i'm just telling you they're saying i'm
not saying it to you they're saying
kevin why don't you just tell us
how you feel instead of deflecting like
the charlie said i'll tell you right
here
you want to hear it you want to hear it
yeah i want to hear it let's hear it
tell us the answer is
i don't spew [ __ ] when i don't know
the answers
i get the facts and when i get the facts
i make videos that are accurate and i
provide information that's accurate
if i get asked questions i don't know
the answer guess what i'm gonna have the
balls to say i don't have the answer
yeah but so if somebody thinks that's
being a politician yeah oh well
then don't vote for me but the reality
is you're gonna get the truth from me
and i'm gonna get the facts before i say
okay so let's go to what you just said
let's go to what you just said
okay you said you were covering the
trump campaign
that's a fact this is a fact so you were
covering the trump campaign this is not
a hypothetical this is you
your experience as a youtuber yes those
videos disappeared
why did they well but again youtube
makes the argument that trump was
inciting violence i believe that's too
far
i believe that goes too far so how do
you address that well
as governor you you can certainly
address that but again we've got to get
into all of the details i want to see
what's going on in the back rooms
i want to see who are the people making
the decisions are these algorithms
making decisions do those need to be
tweaked because we know algorithms have
a lot of human bias and that human bias
gets amplified
you see there's so much more nuance in
everything in our lives in our society
there's so much more nuance and when we
look at the actual details like we break
apart the high-speed rail and we go oh
my gosh it's 200 million
a mile through hilly areas and 100
million dollars a mile through flat
areas
all of a sudden we're going why aren't
we building tunnels for 10 million a
mile
the point is when we get the facts we
can give answers
if i don't have the facts i can't give
you an answer so why don't we move on
from censorship and get on to another
topic where i can give you some answers
yeah but but the challenge is the
challenges the challenge is kevin you're
running
for a governor in a state that
facebook's in you're running in a state
where everyone that's doing that that is
a big
part of your state you're running so if
you don't have an answer for that voters
are going to be like i don't know about
this because
to be able to go face these virtual for
example let me ask you a simpler
question
if if tomorrow facebook or google said
hey we want to back up your campaign
would you support it
well look here's the thing i have uh
donations right now
that average fifty dollars per person if
one media or one tech company came in
like they do for gavin newsom the co-ceo
of netflix donated three million dollars
so that yup did avenue some hastings
yeah yeah exactly that's a lot of money
and the problem is in california you
have to make sure
that you're not going into office with a
ton of strings attached
and that's how i want to run my campaign
is i want to go in as a transparent
youtuber
as a transparent business person not
with political baggage people ask me
what's the difference between you
and a politician who's been in for 20
years well i'll tell you the difference
they've got 20 years of political
baggage and favors to pay back i'll take
donations from anybody who supports my
plan my 20-point plan you support that
20-point plan
you're willing to help make that happen
facebook comes to me and says kevin your
idea of future schools
that's what we want we will fund that
two thousand dollars a month
because we're going to show you how to
educate people in future schools
so that we can hire them at 18 debt free
and they can have a career
rather than 33 percent of californians
going on medi-cal i support that
facebook comes in and goes look you know
this three million dollars is
conditioned upon you uh supporting all
our censorship
then f off it ain't gonna happen so
again there's nuance
in absolutely everything somebody comes
in says i support your plan
i want that kind of california let's go
let's work together
i'll be honest i like the answer because
politicians would say
anything they want to that audience at
that day and then change it the next day
i mean i think there's some value i got
to tell you this here's the thing
like good for him for giving the answer
that he gave which means if facebook or
google gave he would accept the money he
didn't say i wouldn't take a penny
from them and then six months later you
find out he just took six million
dollars whatever the amount is from them
yeah so that's good that's a good answer
that's a real answer so yeah the
audience cannot make a decision you're
you're always gonna get
the real answers but that doesn't mean i
have all of the answers in fairness
he's already in 20 minutes been asked
more hard questions than any democrat in
the last four years so congratulations
bring him on man so you said you're a
democrat since when
well when i was 18 i registered as soon
as i could okay so got a credit card too
that's interesting uh my my buddy who in
fairness is a political operative in new
jersey okay
and he he is a republican he posted uh
harry reid in 2012 when
this is in response to there's a shot
putter who didn't want to stand for
the the uh american flag during i'm
sorry for the
national anthem and it became a thing it
was kneeling in that yeah yeah so
there was a big nice which one you want
pick it uh
oh what do you want all right i'm not a
hard liquor guy anymore yeah
are you running for the governor lead us
which one we're going
for all right we're going with this
there we go so long story short
he posted how far the democrats have
gone all right because
i believe that you know i've been
centered for a long time now people
think i'm right
and i'm wondering if i've gone right i'm
taking it as well
the country's scripted left so the first
time we're doing this on live
why are we doing this yeah no anyways
we're just going to have it keep going
this is so good
in 2000 you're all getting rolled by
meet kevin in 2012
meat swing kevin so in 2012 harry reid
actually said when he found out that the
the uniforms the united states of
america uniforms for the olympics were
made in china
he said don't send the teams and burn
the uniforms that was harry reid
about as far left of progressive as you
can get at the time
we've gone from harry reid saying burn
the uniforms because they were made in
china in 2012 to in 2021
cnn posting a glowing review
of the 100 year anniversary of china so
you've been a democrat for 10 years now
what have you seen happen 11 years what
have you seen in the party over that
time
have you seen a far left sprint from
that party and do you still identify
with them as
well well you you always have extremes
right you've got uh like the aoc's on
the very far you've got rand paul on the
very far right
and what's happening is you've got fox
and you've got cnn catering their
programs
to the extremes because it creates the
views
you entrench the political views uh into
a specific audience that comes back
every day
to see what does anderson cooper say
what does tucker carlson say the problem
is
we're not actually having real
discussions and debates in the middle
about solving the real freaking problems
in our country let me ask you a
straight-up question
a short one then you get back do you
think gavin newsom's worried about you
knows about you
is concerned oh they know about us okay
we already have uh we already have
gotten plenty of messages from folks
saying hey i work inside the campaign at
newsome and
they know about you and they're watching
you more than anyone else it makes sense
because guess what
they're branding this as a republican i
just got disconnected i think we're good
okay
uh they're branding this as a republican
recall well guess what happens
when a democrat comes in and starts
gaining legs uh oh
all of your marketing just got shot to
crap they get screwed
and you got a platform with a few
million subscribers
and you got a platform where you're
killing it every time you go live
and you got a platform for the last 12
months every time you did a stimulus
update
people are wanting to learn from you on
how finance works how bitcoin works how
money works we haven't even gotten into
that because your next one
how real estate works yes so let's do
that
this is the last time i drink carbs last
time i drank hard liquor i got stabbed
so let's see the rest of today toast
everything sorry
god
all right let's do it again now so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you